hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the outlast whistleblower
DLC now last was one of my favorite
games of recent years and the
whistleblower DLC should prove to be a
very good extension on what was already
a good formula outlast was great
obviously it's that one at the top of my
list of great horror games and one of my
favorite playthroughs but I'm really
hoping that the whistleblower DLC adds
something really cool what is going on
now I'm waking up in a bit of a fog oh
hello you here to help me you here to
hurt me
okay oh I'm dead I'm not dead am i dead
what are you doing to me why do you need
radiation suits to help
[Music]
we're not happy about it come on I'm
still upset the fact that you gave me a
wet willy Wally does you literally just
use your tongue and didn't lick your
finger what's going on here move Oh two
hours earlier
so does this take place over the course
of two hours is that what you're trying
to tell me here you don't know me you
have to make this quick they might be
monitoring I did two weeks of software
consult in Murkoff psychiatric system
facilities in Mount massive also sandy a
sine breaker much right now that is the
letter from the first part of the game
that the reporter miles Upshur or Mike
upar got and I am the guy that is
actually telling the story about what is
going on in Mal massive asylum just to
catch you guys up on what's actually
happening willing to bet that this isn't
gonna go too well for this guy he's
gonna get to finish this email and he's
gonna get a wet Wally in his back side
of his ear one of the other things that
needs to be said Oh send send that bad
boy playing games watching porn you
don't need a beep worried about anything
Oh they've paid for you three times
already
oh okay yeah because Billy Hope is about
anyone I thought you were just offering
yeah those are in there I'm just a
weirdo IT guy don't mind me you think I
did lick my here yeah really
the doctor was predicting assembly by
150 this is an interesting conversation
information to try somewhere Nikki's
predictions okay maybe okay cool
you're inventing a diabolical demon
that's gonna rip apart every single
person in here
[Music]
thank you sir how about you am I not
supposed to go that way all right
this is back towards the end of the
first game oh by the way if you haven't
seen the first part up if you haven't
seen outlast in beginning it's one of my
best playthroughs I loved it to death
you can find a link in the description
below to get the whole story thank you
thank you sir sorry to keep a wig and
some urgent business that you need not
be a gotcha yeah hey Jim again we need
this part guy in here now I am here
right here geez oh I get it I get it
final yeah okay you are definitely the
guy that licked my ear right boss you
got it I'm here to help not to make
everything go wonky crazy psycho bunkers
for some reason I'm reminded of
half-life the half-life opening it's a
functional in our friend mr. Waylan yeah
this guy's on my side they're bringing
it he likes a little me a little too
much if you know what I mean oh is that
the guy is that Billy hope
[Music]
he's going off to a great start ago hi
hey handsome how you doing hey hello
yourself
this is a high security alright yeah I'm
sure he's still calm and he gonna finish
his work
calm and eager for you to lick my ear
thank you friend
five seconds all right
oh hi you are Billy hope aren't you
I remember that setup you got going on
there it's gonna go good oh oh that poor
: park leave thank you nothing but kind
to me y'all are really weird
alright what happens if I stay I'm just
gonna hang around for a little bit and
watch all of your cool things going on
here you have five kinds of cancer
there's so much talking going on that I
can't see what's going on dialogue down
below okay I'm out of here childhood
sexual reptile imagery what the hell is
that someone awesome no no cut what what
is that what in the world are you
talking about in there you're very weird
and things are about to go very very
wrong and I just called a reporter over
right when things are about to go to
hell I go back to my little desk inside
of a dark room or I can just send emails
to random strangers but from Close
Encounters okay so oh I am supposed to
go back in here okay you got it
down totally Raju I can see them right
here my friend Thank You mr. Waylon Park
consulting contract 8208 software
engineer with a level three security
clearance yeah
graduated [ __ ] laude from Berkeley so
they still somehow not smart enough to
realize that the last thing a fly on to
do in a spider's web
Oh dumb enough to think that a borrowed
laptop onion router and firewall patch
would be enough to fool the world's
leading supplier of biometrics did you
hear that
oh okay oh and did I just hear mr.
Waylon Park volunteer for the
morphogenic engine program summer cough
corporation and the onward march of
science both appreciate your bravery and
sacrifice maybe you could administer mr.
Park here a light anesthetic oh I wonder
what this is gonna be yep jeez was that
necessary
okay all right now we're actually into a
head that was one hell of an opening you
gotta admit holy hell jeez man you light
up on me I just sent one email oh now
I'm oh now I'm here I thought those at
the end of the game was a phone
okay that was burned into my brain
that's good if I remember the
morphogenetic engine it's like a series
of images that instills like it causes
brain changes that it causes brain
changes that allows the person to tap
into the psychotic okay oh I get a
camcorder just like in the first one I
get a camcorder I don't think I want to
see this oh that's good
that's so good for me oh good one of the
great things hold that is intestines on
the wall how delightful one of the great
things about the first game was that it
was so well made there was a lot of
intricate stuff happening both in the
animation and it falls at Ojai
[Music]
what let go let go let go
oh my go bye thank you for letting me
out I'm just gonna go on my way now and
you can f off forever and ever and ever
and ever and ever and ever and ever
okay friggin out in the bathroom this
cosine anything in here anything in
erisa know about know how to play it's
been a while since I played the original
and now I gotta play Oh batteries guy
need a battery so I get the light the
nectar of night revision in light of
nothing oh hi
that's that's hi I'm not looking at you
please stop staring at me I know you're
still stare go okay you're staring at me
everybody just the another morphogenetic
engine patient coming along what I think
I think I'll pass on this one
scarred by oh hi
Billy I was about to Dibble my giblets
April my giblets Billy up was go back go
went inside my chest and first out like
an apricot alright I'm on my way think I
need to pick up that battery again
probably oh no I got it
thankfully it's nice enough for me to
not oh good I'll hide in here from Billy
it's a good room it's good there's a lot
of cameras around here for a
high-security place to have to think
that is quite odd and that is quite
spectacular how that exploded like that
go this way
Billy on I think Billy's gone hey buddy
coast is clear you can come out now it's
totally fine bro oh geez hey that's guys
naked come back here if you guys watched
cry made a really good abridged version
about them okay fry cryonic made a
really good abridge to outlast Siri
video oh hi hi
[Music]
okay cool yeah no no no okay cool cool
thank you thank you sir with your lovely
arms looking good you've been lifting
weights look like yeah I'll just get out
of here god this is like the freakiest
intro to a game I've ever played
oh hi are you there you are there I
didn't think that you're actually gonna
do anything Jesus God things went to
[ __ ] here really quickly didn't they how
do I go what do what do i do what do i
do what do i do what do i do what do i
do oh I see okay well something fun is
happening over there but I think I'd
rather go this way if you don't mind me
I'm just gonna go up here into the vents
and never see your sorry asses ever
again I have totally forgotten how to
play good god yes yeah yeah
[Music]
rather than be dead yeah well then now
that we've made that clear now we
understand each other now we can go into
hell and a whole new meaning friends for
oh hi
no thank you could you stop could you
stop with that well you don't like me
filming you breath fill me all I want
bear be scared of me
get up that's right stay on your ball
[Music]
gotta push this out of the way oh my
friend
come help me help came to help so he
came to Joe thank you thank you friend
good god oh oh man I really like this
game well the reason why I liked outlast
the river
[Music]
nevermind I didn't like it at all never
liked it anything about it was actually
a crap game that it was really bad
this is where I started why am I here
why did I need to come all the way back
to here
oh hi okay yeah that's definitely where
I was before I went through that hole in
the wall over there
okay I gotta okay I got unlocked this
anyway one of the things that I really
liked about Atlas was how how committed
they word of a theme they pulled no
punches on it on everything like just
look at that it's horrifying but it's
got a mixture of gore like the the old
splatterhouse horror movies of yonder
year like uh just enormous bouts of war
and also at the same time just a general
creep factor that caught you don't get
on a lot of games dead body i sense okay
don't seem to have any other choice in
you sir themed trustworthy with all your
blood on you i mean that's a good look
for you that in the new fall fashion Oh
[Music]
not me though not me though I'm a friend
okay okay yeah sorry I'm crazy psycho
you better stay back I'm a loose cannon
you'll never know what I'm gonna do next
might just do something you will regret
this looks final I think I'll just
wander outside did those guys actually
make it outside or they just kidding
themselves then it fell here and died
instantaneously oh look
the first document I found ms grant you
may receive requests for information
from miss Lee's Park of Linville
Colorado in the coming weeks and
concerning recognition and
hospitalization of her husband Wayland
my goodness I can't have talked if so
please forward them to my personal
attention Waylon Park resigned due to
previous undiagnosed mental illness I
personally visited mrs. Lisa Park and
her sons and broke the news to them with
the silver lining that Murkoff
psychiatric would be graciously
providing treatment miss Park had some
less than charitable things to say about
myself in the Murkoff corporation
I sure do that with her power of
attorney she could try to fight the
doctor's diagnosis of her husband's
illness however if it were discovered
that he designed under false pretences
insurance would be canceled and the
family would be saddled with not
insignificant health care debts
hopefully she understood but if she
insists on making a nuisance of herself
or tries to get around me please let me
know this is one I want to take care of
personally Jeremy Blair why do I have a
reporter's notebook I'm not a reporter
I'm just a tech guy I'm an IT man all I
do is play around with files and
hardware and software and make people's
heads go boom in the night what
what that God quiet quick why oh why
can't I jump up that it very much seems
that I need to go up here oh this seem
okay this is worse than a music turnouts
a friggin ambience so I love you got
about to jump out of me
I hear a groaning dude you're right in
there you having trouble like down at
something hard and push you got it
I believe in you show that turd who's
boss yeah my way now I guess I can go
this way maybe no there's got to be a
way that I can do something up there
I've got to be able to get up there I
need to be able to push something this
has got to be like another thing that I
can push up cuz I mean this very
obviously seems like some place that I'm
supposed to climb up but I fine come on
man get down with your bad self by
getting up there oh maybe that's oh I'm
a friggin idiot I apologize everybody
I'm so terribly stupid I'm so terribly
stupid I'm so terribly done my brain
just doesn't cooperate morphogenic
engine being make him up
looky cool beans
I like to scream at the dam feel that
doctors lying everywhere picture that
priest guy it's good it's good
can I climb through there well I want to
climb through here alright there's so
many pictures of strange things replace
my battery don't see anything I need in
here maybe maybe not maybe baby here no
it's just a door back to where I was
okay there was no point in coming my way
okay time to parkour my way out of
victory hello dead below hi was that did
you just pull the head off of someone
what are you doing over there okay you
naked be much better if you're naked
don't ask me why you might be naked okay
I'm just gonna be very cautious about
this to not alert you to my presence
because Christmas isn't anytime soon oh
you like to cook somebody eating okay
oh oh oh boy I think this whole
playthrough I haven't even been able to
say anything clever all I've been doing
is just going oh that's disgusting hi
nice beard or is that just the entrails
of the fallen on your face I'm not one
to stop your love did you microwave his
head until his brain exploded oh god
that's so gross Oh
so girls why am I still looking at do
not follow me and chase me dude if you
do I will be very forced to run away
from you screaming like a little girl
and I don't want to do that to my lovely
fans actually they probably love to see
that home in this bathroom which is
always good thing in horror games lots
of hiding spaces for me to get nothing
nothing house nothing probably nothing
morphogenic engine up in my eyeballs
it's nothing a lot of nothing
fun funfun
no oh I don't know what you did but it
probably needed to go that way so please
don't like the handcuffs oh good I gotta
go back and find the key good for me
all right anyway this seems like a good
place to stop this part I went on a
little longer than I thought just cuz I
was in a really into this story but
either way this is awesome it's like
it's a shame because outlast doesn't
have like custom stories like amnesia
does so you can only get these in
official doses from the creators but
that means it's always gonna be a very
cool experience so this is a dead set
awesome dedicated to outlast DLC er and
I can't wait to play more I can't wait
to see what other surprises are in store
for me so anyway thank you all so much
for watching if you enjoy this video
leave a like to let me know let me know
what you think in the comments below and
as always I will see you in the next
[Music]
our Odyssey
galaxies are gonna be very very